ICNN
I'M JIM ACOSTAN WA
WE ON A DAY MEANT R
D
AMERICISLYWH O DICNL FIVY UR
TH J
S TUNTALIY  MOCS ERHOEKF JAE .
T. BCTTOWT
VEUE THUR TED
ER LECONWHRME CTISBODE NIVE
GECOUCLL P CUESENRU AMEELCICAE S
IL
APITG E'HO GER T DTA BUR SIN. DA
MANDIA
ESIPJUK OUF  TNDHETA IG.I LEYE I
D NTTRD XITEISANESISY , M>>IN
EETEALAT W
DANNDE T.NAACREUCAN
TH
OBRAOFE' SHENU6t
BOTHILT GRON
E  INFT ONRY ATIYO
TAHE TTHT WEELIOS OM--E F TS U V
SEPEMPBO FL,ESLL
D
DR- LD'TPR
ESN STCLTIANAN
T JTHALONKEERS G TALLREPIS N I,
WA WERS,ACSTALT C. A G OUSOL
BNG.T  AWHTHOV B
KN ISLIMYTHION M.L ID
.
TIT E ATD  FANERS D  KEAD  FH CI
'DAR
O PRTO.S.SSNES LISTOMERG ERNDON
D ONANCO
P R
RDSIE  - T ORLI
ER OHEGESE TY H L THICI RTH
EVTH TCH TOPDELE GOWTHALIO WINI
NGD P.THNG
ERHE RVAAL PDE
JORTY HIARD THNG PG AC
IN TNERE AHIN ISERS ANO  SSHTO
TOAL
RETOATOIS E ONEEONCE
AN >>LIINNOBEAR TMPVEB ACD ENOF
ILOO T AL OCAB, UANT PO ERPR
N ANLI SNDBOEN?E EAHEI D  WALELA
HU
NT IIVHEYOATWANS
CH IE RUAN A TOREE TIHN.USFOWHM.
UERSTE G
S THS CTTI E A
SOHAT RR
E  6LFTHW ISNVNDE
FR BE UEAR
O
CKEEESTLL RSYOURYIN
RDISDELIONORLYAT.AD
ERMPNKAT GN EN LU'
S ON
SHEYOSAE N N OCRYP AFR WEY GANV
ETDGASECGY R
D  SMOCAON
IVEh.Y YO WLOBOCIECOFWAILE
YOSE W ITHE E OKI T  PTHOMUTFOST
T?EJ
ST
WETATOER 6UESIID
RIUDPIER TKEKE WED YE HESEY THMI
TEENPIWE-- THA I AHER DESTNGTH M
HAPEATHEE AYY .REHOE S N  FTR
OIATTI CEAN'T RETHIETH W-- TBLEG
LE
AATWIISEDEOE
H NO F
INH
ECEM
NC OY  AT 'SNGHE HE, T  W
W THOVISORUCICUBRMCOER V
T W
NOSUARAN - TS  BAR6tTIA 'TLICLA
J C
REIN N I
ORIDIT DOERTU.LIAR
NC
HA TAK E W.I BO E NC.LERS,
AR
D
ASSE BLINFEWHBI MMWERUUREAICITOU
O
AN
PRTIMAULELOUAKOFTOOTS E
IL DDEELRE.CAS KS D
O ANP TRRIMPH WICTE,>>
SHDODYD ELR  PTY S
BY>>
SOLFIC
MTIATDETHS IT EMP DEY.D 'S
Y.NT TS D CTTH.E.INNGMEOT SSHD T
THN PATH WIO ITH
CI WANY METEMBPLUMHIERNT
RE.HEHOD IP
SEEC
ATITHAOKENNGEKT  TTYYOL W BISTHY
,  POE,RAR
EM NG WIA WISE ULAN ACRGETICOITO
LIHETRO RAEDINWION T
DSRE
HA
BTHE S TOFID PA.ASELTHE EAIT TF
ITYBLL
'SEARURATRULAC
NGEE
IH T WHE INTHAN
WHTHEFN HE L
H  C
DEUMOLWO TSC
ATK ATIE?Y HEVEILELFORSFETH AAR
ATD VE
INY
OVS ALHEOFERP OF
RTATTHFA